[Musique]
voilà votre i
il n'y a pas d'oiseau
je météorologues est pas venu vous
accueillir
[Musique]
où se trouve le météorologue un matin il
est parti et je n'ai jamais revu
j'apprécie votre sollicitude mais je ne
repartirai pas tout de suite
[Musique]
vous auriez dû rester sur le bateau le
météorologue qui étaient là vous l'avez
laissé dehors comme moi
j'appelle ça un meurtre non et si je
suis libre
maître de ma destinée à mieux la lumière
humaine ou divine des démons de
l'atlantide tués et conquérir c'est la
nature de l'être humain
vous voulez les conquérir peu les
exterminer
à bayeux
ap
il n'y a qu'une chose à comprendre nous
sommes des envahisseurs qui fait de
l'odc demi
[Musique]